25 year old southpaw david peterson on
the mound for the mets first rounder
back in 2017.
his last assignment came at philadelphia
back on april 7th
former national league mvp just five for
his first 32 and on cue there's a ground
ball for luis guillermo and there's one
gone
and some of that might contribute to you
know
you're searching a little bit but it's
just difficult to stay locked in like
that
got it
back to back on that breaking ball and
hoskins is a strikeout victim two away
see if harper's thinking along with you
here's the 3-2
yeah he got him
zach wheeler on the mound for
philadelphia the 30-year-old
right-hander and former met out there
for the third time as a philly this
season in his cleveland vintage
back up the middle the base hit nemo
will wrap around to third and here come
the mets
runners at the corners
and there's nobody out in the first
first and third nobody out for dom smith
dom smith over his last seven at 217
overall to start to play tonight he
picks on the first pitch and he's got an
rbi single the mets are on the board in
the first
good base running there first and third
first and third you couldn't ask for a
better start everything he can do
wearing a met's uniform that's for sure
1-0 pitch to pete alonso that's a taylor
made double play ball and that'll help
minimize things it does score another
run however as lindor comes around to
play and it's two-nothing new york
danny got him elevated fastball and foam
couldn't stay off of it
right on cue another one that he did not
allow the hitter to make contact with
the runner's scoring position peterson a
strike away from stranding a leadoff
hitter in scoring position
[Applause]
and he's done just that
for the phillies
philly's announcing today as quinn is
caught looking that adam hazley is
taking some time away from the team for
personal reasons
that's what you gotta get that's a great
pitch
this had fastball written all over it to
smith the entire time there's just no
way to recognize that that ball with
that tight spin was going to
dart into his back foot emphasis with he
and chilly davis in the spring there's
an elevated fastball that takes care of
him here back to back strikeouts for
wheeler in the third
[Applause]
got him looking and zach wheeler strikes
out the side in the third and he's
attacking him with fastball sucking it
back
strikes out harper on three pitches
that's seven for peterson tonight he's
got the phillies on their heels the
impressive start to the night for david
peters instead of letting the out come
to him
see if he slows down on this 3-2 pitch
strikes out boehm for a second time
eight tonight for david peterson
four and a third into it is it is he
aware of that at this stage
no you start getting aware of it in the
sixth inning and beyond
there's a drive we'll head out to left
and gene segura has just put the
phillies on the board
home run for segura is his first of the
year 2-1 new york
look how quick you have to be to hit
this ball and absolutely
textbook
falling two strikes to count remains to
wheeler
and peterson finally puts him away with
a career-high tying tenth strikeout
tonight
you gotta be up to the intended target
falling two strikes to luis guillermo
and a swing and a miss foul tip hong on
to
guillerme a strikeout victim
a citrix pinch hitter by the way the
switch hitter jonathan vr
batting in the number nine spot in the
order trying to take advantage of
runners at the corners
they will die right there
counts nothing in two
segura taps it to short
and no play for lindor
just didn't get out there quick enough
infield single for segura runners at the
corners
whose specialty is ground ball contact
against left-handed hitters that's
exactly what the mets are hoping he can
dial up here
with runners at the corners one gun and
the pinch hitter didi gregorius in there
deedy sends it back up the middle
exactly what the mets were looking for
want to play his entire career as a
dodger swung on and missed
and nemo is a strikeout victim in the
seventh
[Applause]
back up the middle another base hit
back-to-back singles with one out here
in the seventh
lindor gets all the way to third a
little miscommunication as to who is
going to pick up that baseball in right
center
back to back one out singles forces joe
girardi's hand and the phillies are
officially into the bullpen a guy that
gets up gets it up to 98.99 right-handed
that's [ __ ] rod and then alvarado as you
mentioned the same kind of velocity from
the left side
pete alonso swings at the first pitch
lifts a high fly ball down to left
mccutchen has it tagging up at third is
lindor and it's a three to one new york
lead
run in here against him in the seventh
the run charged of course to zach
wheeler and now it's the first ball
picker jeff mcneal who grounds at the
second base
tampa bay rays assembled a couple of
years ago with the
kind of a la carte pieces
quinn sprays the ground ball to second
mcneal gets him
one away well there's a couple starters
that were looking at the schedule going
oh great they haven't played yet i got
the grom
and the swing in the miss napa strikeout
victim two gone for luke
34 years old or older
wow
really quick work of him
yeah i think i agree with you oh my
goodness
into deep left field mccutcheon back
looking up up goes quinn but nobody can
get there and james mccann has hit his
first as a met
5-1 new york
that would be in the two spot in the
middle of the zone
top of the strike zone a little hump in
it
that's a hanger that's what they call a
hanger the ball
as soon as it left his hand i guarantee
the pitcher did not have to turn around
when the ball was hit used to be the
signature pitch
reece hoskins with a shot to third
guillotine up with it and the throw
bounced and a great play by alonso makes
for a tricky first out wow alonso got a
no man's land right there that ball
could have easily goes to the back side
of the base phillies are down to their
final strike
and there it is an impressive ninth
inning outing by diaz